las d'attendre dans la rue jehan ces
deux petits pavés sûreté carreaux que
j'ai crevé mais tu ne mets pas à pabu tu
te moques de tout je crois
tu te moques de tout je crois demain je
t'en serai 3par devant ta porte cochère
pour faire tomber des amis 3 au 4 août
pavé gmi j'exècre tes amis pas cher
demain j'ai encore ans au vert
demain je recommencerai étaient amants
je les tuerai
si tu ne changes pas d'annuaire j'écrase
ray des yeux ton front entre deux pavés
qui feront at on craque quelques fêlures
je t'aime je t'aime bien pourtant je
t'aime
je te veux bien pourtant mais tu m'en a
fait tant de temps les gendarmes agents
cavalca m'arrêteront d'après ce coup
pour me mettre la corde au cou je me
construis ma barricades et sur les pavés
je mettrai et sur les pavés je mettrai
mon coeur durci par leur gré autant de
pavés par le monde
de grands et de petits pavés autant de
chagrin en cave et dans ma pauvre un
vagabond je meurs je meurs de tout cela
je meurs je meurs de tous cela est ma
chanson ça va être là